to is a wonderful thing to watch yeah we
were saying we've seen a lot of those
lately is it easier than it looks
I don't think so yeah I don't think so
either there's a lot of them but I like
it when people do it yes welcome back to
CBS this morning we begin of course with
the coronavirus because it continues to
spread across the world and right here
in this country where a second person
has now died
Mitchell's say a man in his 70s died
over the weekend at the Evergreen Health
Medical Center that's just outside
Seattle Washington there are now cases
of the potentially deadly virus in 12
different states and that includes New
York which just confirmed its first case
in New York City officials say a female
health care worker in her 30s is
isolated in her Manhattan home after
contracting the virus in Iran America is
one of at least 67 countries with
coronavirus Italy has been hit
especially hard and Charlie d'Agata is
there for us in Rome charlie good
morning what are you seeing good morning
well it's kind of what we're not seeing
and that's a ton of tourists outside the
Coliseum which would normally be heaving
now hotels are empty too and we're now
hearing that the first case has been
detected here in Rome here's what Venice
looks like now not much more than a week
after many are aware the coronavirus had
arrived the number of cases in Italy
soared by 50% on Sunday - more than 1700
people have even been worried about the
health of Pope Francis who had to pause
to cough a couple of times during
yesterday's prayers Vatican officials
tell us his holiness just has a pretty
bad cold at a time where many people are
a little bit worried about gathering in
large crowds the fear of spreading the
virus well the numbers here seem a lot
lighter than usual when the US State
Department up the travel advisory here
to its highest level rosemary Macmillan
from Nebraska faced calls from parents
at her daughter's school I had parents
calling me and saying well what are your
contingency plans for when you arrive
back like we were going to put ourselves
in quarantine and I was just like no
that's in Paris the Lea shut its doors
over staff concerns the Health Minister
suggested people stop kissing when they
meet
though marathon runners defied a ban on
events larger than 5,000 people in
Germany Chancellor Angela Merkel at a
handshake turned down for today's
election Israel is set up voting
stations for those in quarantine with
staff in full hazmat gear but outside of
China nowhere has been hit harder than
South Korea where cases keep climbing
now at more than 4300 people
now most people we've spoken to here say
the hype has been overblown but we met a
couple who arrived here off a cruise
from Island they tried to buy some hand
sanitizer like this about this size they
were told it was going to cost him
around 22 bucks
Anthony early day you know well in Rome
thanks charlie